imagine ...
a soldier
the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon
if you give God-like powers to everyone
It's going to be chaos
So how do we stop him?
I know a guy.
Scott
I've been watching for a while
you're different
and I believe everyone deserves a shot at redemption
Do you?
absolutely
my days of breaking into places and stealing stuff
are over
What do you want me to do?
I want you to break into a place and steal some stuff
makes sense
Are you ready
to become the hero?
Now the suit has powers
You have to learn how to control it
and these are your greatest allies
You're kind of cute!
Whoa!
when you're small
have super-human strength
you're like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch
you're wanna show me how to punch?
show me how to punch...
that's how you punch.
you tried to to hide your suit me
Now, it's going to blow up in your face
and destroy everyone you care about
Scott, get out of there!
Did you think you could stop the future
you're just a thief
NO
I'm Ant-Man
I know, it wasn't my idea
Hey YouTubers it's Charlie
So new Ant-Man trailer
so this is gonna be a breakdown video
I'll also explain how it fits into MCU
Marvel just did an Age of Ultron press conference
where they gave out a lot of details about
of you know, thematically
where Ant-Man is supposed to fit with all these big Avengers films
so 6 billion dollar question
where does this movie fit in with all the other big stuff
Kevin Feige said that this is like a bookend for phase 2
its like a different kind of book end
because technically Age of Ultron
is the last phase 2 film
what this does
is fill in the lot of gaps
of 60's 70's and 80's in the marvel universe
Movies and TV Shows
haven't spend a lot of time in those decades
like we see  in Agent Carter
which is like the beginning
but we haven't seen the lot of middle stuff
thats when the Hank Pym's character comes in
so you learn a lot what's been happening
between agent carter and the first iron man film
The film itself takes place after Avengers Age of Ultron
they said that a lot of the decisions Hank Pym
makes in the movie are based on what happens at the end of Age of Ultron
I think the same thing can be said for  Yellowjacket the villain here
this trailer really explains the story of the movie
in a much bigger way than the previous trailers have
Yellowjacket is now the head of Pym's company
Pym is like the old man that's kinda been pushed out
His daughter, Hope Van Dyne,
very much involved with the day to day stuff
Imagine a punchier, kickier version of  Pepper Potts
Evangeline Lilly
awesome in the Hobbit movies,
I think she has high potential
to wind up in a future Avengers film.
Like in Avengers 3
What I'm hoping is
is that once they steal back the Yellowjacket suit,
they'll modify it and she'll wear that
and become The Wasp
I know everybody misses Janet Van Dyne
but they said they would explain where she is in this movie
Most of these tech-looking shots are from inside Pym Tech
with the exception of Hank Pym's lab
They do a good job of showing the scale of like how Ant-Man
gets stronger as he gets smaller
It's the same principle behind the strength of ants
So he can kick the shit out of people when he's super small
Even though he's a weakling when he's normal sized.
A big thing about the movie, and what's going to lead up into Avengers 3
is that even regular people can be heroes, too
That's kind of what's going on in Daredevil right now, you know, street-level heroes
Scott Lang is just another twist on that
even dirt bags can be heroes
I don't know if I'd call him a dirt bag,
but I think it's a better description of where his character starts out
The movie explains his origin story
about how he steals to support his daughter
So he's a dirt bag out of necessity
As they explain, Yellowjacket's plan
is to create an army of ANTMEN
in order to do that he needs Pym particles
like, you can build the suits, but in order to shrink you need the Pym particles
He appropriates that from Pym
their disagreement over that is what leads to the heist
I love all these Hank Pym scenes - like this in Pym's lab. You get a sense that he's
been doing this for a long time
He's been the Ant-Man for a long time
That's why the Yellowjacket suit looks more contemporary
And the Ant-Man suit looks like it was built 20 years ago
Whenever you guys go to see the movie
make sure that in all these Hank Pym Lab scenes
you keep your eyes peeled
They're probably full of Easter Eggs
If you're a hardcore Hank Pym Ant-Man fan, these will really be your moments
It's like in GAME OF THRONES where they tell you about Robert's Rebellion
this big adventure that you don't see, they just tell you about it after the fact
Hanks Pym probably explain what made the past 20 years
with the Ant-Man technology.
I'll be interested to see how true his character is to his comic book character
because I always thought of him as like a crazier, mad version of Tony Stark
Like Tony Stark with grayer morality.
All these really small size scenes do a really good job of showing the scale.
You have the real world shrunk down here
and then in the other ant-based scenes
you see him inside an ant farm
really the hard sell of this movie, isn't so much the suit
we understand super suits - shrinking isn't that big of a leap
It's really his ability to communicate with Ants that they need to explain
I feel like if you read comics, it's not a big deal - you totally get it.
you're like, "Ok he can talk to ants"
the problem with big Marvel movies is that they have to explain this stuff
to people who have never read comics before
they're like "Why is he talking to ants? I don't get it"
I like that Hope tells him he's kind of like a bullet when he's small
like he's as strong as a bullet
It seems like they're trying to build some sort of relationship between the two characters
which is why they went with Hope instead of Janet, I think
It's a nice twist on the Pepper Potts/Tony Stark relationship
This is a nice shot of them messing with Pym particles
I'm looking forward to seeing how the movies explain those, versus the comics
The comics are a little opaque with the way they explain them
There's this new type of particle that allows you to do these things
It is like inventing Vibranium because you need a super strong metal
they don't get too deep into the mechanics of Vibranium
it's just like a one sentence explainer
super strong metal... okay, we get it.
I think this train scene was inspired by the LEGO movie
probably the most funniest moment in a Marvel trailer
that I've seen in a long time
aside from science-bro-fist
really, the job of this movie is to sell the Scott Lang character.
They can do action great - Marvel has action down 100%, that's the easy part,
The hard part is making us believe that Scott Lang could go toe-to-toe with Tony Stark, Thor,
all the other Avenger characters.
or that he even deserves to be in their company
But as you can see from this train scene
This is probably going to be the funniest Marvel movie that you've seen so far
I mean, Avengers Age of Ultron has a lot of funny moments
Joss Whedon is a comedic genius
but from the ground up, Ant-Man is built more on comedy than I think the Avengers are
Speaking of which, transitioning into Avengers Age of Ultron stuff
So I'm going to be seeing an early screening next week
so what I'm going to do is post a non-spoilery review of that after I see it
Be sure to subscribe to get it
I know international people, you'll be seeing it sometime next week, too
so be careful with spoilers whenever I post that video
I also want to give you guys a giant high five and say thank you for the almost 30,000 followers on Twitter and
15,000 on Facebook
if you guys don't know where to find those links, they are in the description below
sometimes I'll live tweet TV shows if I'm not already working on a video
so if you guys want to have fun and play along you can  follow me there.
I'm still working on more DAREDEVIL videos
I'm going to try and slip those in between the other TV shows that are
coming back this week
we have new episodes of GOTHAM, AGENT OF SHIELD, FLASH and ARROW
so I'll try to squeeze the rest of my DAREDEVIL videos in
in the next week or two
if  you guys haven't been watching it, seriously, find a way - it is amazing.
some have asked me how to submit fan subs for videos
if you want to do that for a video all you have to do is go into the CC menu it will have an option for adding subtitles.
the other way would be to just type up a transcript and then message it to me on my channel.
thank you so much, though, people that submit fan subs, it's a huge help. ((you're welcome, Charlie))
over 50% of you guys live outside of the United States
which I think is just awesome
So in case you guys haven't seen it or you're not caught up yet you can
click here for my GAME OF THRONES Episode 1 review from last night
It's going to be a crazy season seriously you guys need to watch it
and you can click here for my latest Daredevil video
Also, probably best new TV series Marvel has.
Thank you so much for watching everybody. Let's HIGH FIVE!
I'll see you guys tonight.